[Music]
or something okay a big anniversary
coming up in October it's the 20th
anniversary of the Charmed premier how
are you gonna be celebrating this
magical minds milestone do you still
keep in touch with the cast I do I keep
in touch with the cast I don't know that
I'll be celebrating but it feels like
yesterday but it's it's pretty cool it
is a milestone lastly there's the
charmed reboot that is coming out this
year Holly's been vocal about her
thoughts on it Rose McGowan just
recently came out and said that she
fully supports the show and wishes them
the best what are your thoughts on it
um I wish that they would have come to
us and we would have been involved since
the beginning but having said that I do
hope that it reaches the newer
generation and impacts that generation
the way ours was able to do for its
generation I loved the original charmed
would you ever want to maybe make a
cameo or even direct an episode I don't
think so I think I think that that ship
has sailed for me this is like every
great high school movie ever made
now I could be the former fatty who
turned into a brain ET spoke with milano
at the red carpet of insatiable her new
Netflix series where she explained why
she was so drawn to her character corley
I mean I think that was just it you know
being able to straddle that line between
being completely ridiculously
over-the-top in this in the southern
character but also find moments of her
own truth in her own groundedness and
she was just you know to be given this
this gift of a roll at 45 years old has
been
so lovely
[Music]